Jeremy Foley, Filmmaker/Actor/Screenwriter: I
would keep...what is that seven?That's something
I would keep. I would keep
Sam Raimi's Army of Darkness, a lot of people
say Evil Dead II, I'm not one of those people.
Film Courage: Do you still own dvds and blu-rays?
Jeremy: Not only do I still own
dvds and blu-rays but I buy them
constantly and it can be a little bit of a...
cause a little bit of friction with my wife's here
because if we go into a record store
or a dvd or any place where they sell
blu-rays and dvds I'm going come out with at least
a dozen because and the reason is because I think
and actually I know and I'm not the only person
who feels this way that physical media is going
to go away in a big way that blu-rays are going
to be I think the last high definition or I guess
they have ultra high def blu-rays now but this
is really going to be the last piece of physical
media for movies that we own. So I'm buying as
many as I can and I love film and television.
I have oh gosh hundreds of blu-rays and dvds in
my collection (everything) and I just feel like
there's it's interesting because I think for like
a filmmaker or like a writer or an actor you know
we use them i use them to like reference like if
i've got an idea for a scene or for a piece of
dialogue or for a camera move i'm like what movie
have i seen that in oh gosh i remember they did
this really cool dolly shot in this movie i go to
my collection i grab it i put it on i watch that
part and i'm like oh yeah that's it okay cool and
then i'll i'll do a shot list usually i i do a lot
of this even before like making something like i'd
watch a lot of my favorite films just so that sort
of like filmic sort of like visual language gets
just quickly imprinted and it's it's very um very
fresh in my mind but yeah i love blu-rays and dvds
i always buy them i buy them as often as i can
what if the technology that you have to play
them on now you've got this physical media
it breaks down yeah is there an obscure shop
somewhere that there's going to be a guy that
knows how to fix it what if that goes away i
think there is i'll learn how to fix it myself
i'll really no i'm kidding but um i you
know i think um that could happen i mean
you know like who knows how to work a vcr anymore
you know how to fix one i don't but i'm sure
there's somebody out there that that's good
at stuff like that that can do it but um
yeah i i just feel like it's so important to hang
on to for me at least the physical media because i
do also own some films as like digital copies you
know that we have on the cloud or whatever but i'm
always so nervous of those like um i think it's
more likely that something might happen and those
get deleted as opposed to my physical media which
is like a tangible disc that i can hold in my hand
so yeah i i love it and it's never going to go
away for me it's never going to go away like i
um i'm going to keep on buying blu-rays until
they stop making them how do you have it organized
i you know i don't have it organized i do
have it organized by um blu-rays and dvds
and i try not to as best i can because i have
a lot and it is kind of like a problem for me
like i said whenever i go anywhere and if they
sell blu-rays or dvds i'm gonna get some but uh
i try not to buy things that i have on dvd again
on blu-ray even though i might want to because
there has to be some point that i cut myself off
otherwise i'm just gonna buy all these movies
that i already own so i try and try not to do that
there's there are quite a few that i i do own both
but i do have them organized by dvds and i
have my blu-rays and but that's it like i
don't get into alphabetizing or um doing it by
genre that's too much that's a little too much
work for me and i don't have that much time
um even in the pandemic i didn't do that but
boy i i watched i watched them a lot and like
every you know every like on a friday night like
we'll just i'll pull like a stack of like i don't
know 10 and probably watch about half of them
i love it i love it let's say you
were only allowed to keep 10 movies
what ten would you keep if i was only
allowed to keep ten movies out of my blu-ray
or dvd collection i would keep i would keep
probably all oh man that's tough i would keep
oh gosh oh man that's so hard because you
know there's comedies that i love watching
but like like maybe i would keep like my favorites
um i would keep okay i would keep um here we go
i can do it top top 10 that blu-rays or dvds
i would keep i would keep um i would keep
wes anderson's rushmore i would keep that i would
keep um paul thomas anderson's boogie nights
i would keep um martin scorsese's taxi driver
i would keep um i would keep mike nichols the
graduate i would keep oliver stone's wall street
i would keep michael mann's less than mohicans
i would keep james cameron's terminator two i
would keep what is that seven uh yeah that's
something i would keep um i would keep sam raimi's
army of darkness a lot of people say evil dead too
i'm not one of those people um i would keep
what is that eight uh now you're on nine mm-hmm
oh that was nine or this is not this is not okay
so i would keep oh man you got two more i know
i would keep um alexander payne sideways
and maybe something something different
um there's a movie that i loved it's not super
popular i don't not not too many people maybe
have heard of it or have seen it yet but he's
a he's an actor filmmaker his name is richard
ayawade and he made a movie called submarine
and i just it's it's probably the most recent
movie in that list that i would keep but
i just loved it so i would keep submarine
those are my ten is that it's like a one location
film no no it's a it's a really wonderful story
about kind of a teenage outcast or a teenage sort
of a kind of a awkward kid in high school who you
know it's sort of like a high school romance love
story just about this kind of offbeat quirky kid
who's kind of sort of trying to find himself
and dealing with issues with his parents but
he he's also dealing with this this girl that he
really likes who's who's sort of like kind of like
a little um i mean she's just very like sort of
like mischievous and sort of like really like um
kind of like cocky and and just really like um
kind of dangerous for him you know not not like
him um he's sort of more of a uh oh kind
of kind of quiet kid um but it's just it's
it's made with such great visuals and just so much
personality and such great music um i think it's
like one of those movies that just like to me it's
like explodes off the screen just i like from the
first moment it was on i was like i love this so
that's that's my number 10. do you still have vhs
no i don't i got rid of my vhs i i used to
have a i used to have a ton even when i was
a little boy i loved collecting vhs movies
even before i became an actor i mean i really
you know i've always loved films and
television so now no vhs no no vcr
yeah i don't know if i would even really enjoy
watching them because i think i've gotten so used
to the high def blu-ray quality that we i think
any of us you know anybody any filmmakers out
there watching this i don't know if i would really
enjoy going back and watching those but yeah i got
rid of them i do i have a lot i feel very strongly
that like we really do need if you if people have
them they should really hang on to them because as
we see it now you know studios are releasing stuff
exclusively on netflix or exclusively on amazon
prime or exclusively on hulu or whatever it is
and i just don't think those films are going to
get a blu-ray copy i don't think they're going
to get a physical copy so i really do think that
people should if they you know i think they should
really hang on to their collections because i i
think this is going to be it and what's the most
you've ever paid i remember paying 90 for a dvd
back in the day yeah and i had to order them on
amazon this is about oh my gosh no i've never paid
that it was a long time ago but i really wanted it
and what's the most you ever paid oh man i
don't know i think i bought like very you know
fancy packaging um the most i've ever paid for
something is probably for a single dvd or blu-ray
i don't know maybe 50 or something like that
okay but like that's for like a limited edition
you know fancy box set whatever but um but
yeah it's always money well spent i think
spending money on dvds and blu-rays is
totally fine because uh because you know it's
it's something that you're gonna have forever
and it's gonna bring you so much joy you can
watch it time and time again if you're making
something you can always go back and reference
it if there's something you really loved um i
just think it's it's just totally worth it to me
and um yeah you'll have to ask sarah
about that or my wife about that
because uh yeah i spend you know spend a lot
of money on blu-rays but i think it's okay.
Question For The Viewers: If
you were only allowed to keep 10 of
your movies, which 10 do you keep?